Hello and welcome.
Very good to be with you
and have your company.
How dangerous can fiction really be?
My guest today, a Turkish
writer and political scientist
has been investigated by the
authorities of her home country
for simply writing novels,
accused of being anti-Turkish
and inciting crimes through her writing.
She has fought back and
continued to defy her critics.
Elif Shafak, through her fiction,
including her latest novel,
"The Island of Missing Trees,"
covers politics, identity and
the expectations of women.
She has also won acclaim for
defining the 40 rules of love.
Now a British citizen,
she continues to campaign
for women's rights,
both in what she calls
her motherland, Turkey,
and around the world.
Elif Shafak, welcome.
Thank you so much.
It's lovely to be with you.
I thought we could start
with what you call your
motherland, Turkey.
And do you think that people
outside of Turkey realize
how challenging the
circumstances are inside it?
I don't think many people
realize that Turkey,
as you know, has become a difficult place
for anyone who deals with words,
so, poets, writers,
journalists, of course,
but also cartoonists for instance.
Humor itself can also
be regarded as dangerous
when democracy is lost.
So, that makes it very difficult
when you don't have freedom of speech.
It makes the life of a writer difficult.
Many people, of course, understand
that it might be not that easy
to question political issues,
but sometimes people don't realize
that it's equally challenging
to write about sexuality,
gender discrimination, child abuse.
So, all those issues
can also be very difficult
subjects to tackle.
I want to come to the investigation
of you in short order,
but on that point of our view of Turkey,
outside Turkey, do you think it's outdated
what we think of as Turkey
because what's happened
has been quite gradual?
There's no doubt in my mind,
this is such a beautiful country.
It's a very complex country
and I would never associate
the government and the people.
The civil society in Turkey is, of course,
far more multi-layered, nuanced,
but we do have a vague
conservative government
that has become more and more
authoritarian over the years.
Under Erdogan?
Under Erdogan.
So, what we've seen in Turkey
is the country under Erdogan
has been going backwards
and declining into
ultra-nationalism, Islamism,
populist authoritarianism.
When and where that happens,
we will also see an increase in sexism,
misogyny, homophobia.
In my opinion, these things
always go hand in hand.
That must be many though,
who are in support or
do you see it as a mask?
There are some in support, of course,
but for all kinds of reasons.
And as you pointed out,
this government has been in
power for a very long time.
They came to power with
liberal promises of reform.
At the time they were pro
Turkey's EU membership.
Do you consider Turkey, I say,
used to call it your motherland,
but do you consider it your home?
What is your identity as
far as you're concerned,
because you're someone
who's paid a lot of attention to that?
I care about this question so much.
Identity for me, it's not a
static, solid, single thread.
It's not a monolithic block.
I want to think of identity
as more fluid, more multiple.
And I think as human beings,
we all contain multitudes
like Walt Whitman used to say.
The problem is we're living in a world
that doesn't allow us to be multiple,
let alone celebrate our own multiplicity.
So, for me, rather than
identity, singular,
what I care about more
is multiple belongings.
If I have a singular identity,
if you have a singular identity,
it's much harder for us
to understand what we have in common.
But the moment we understand
and embrace these concentric
circles of belongings,
then we realize actually
so much of it overlaps.
You said of your own country,
your motherland in 2014,
"I get a lot of criticism
from the cultural elite
and a lot of love from readers.
The more you are read
in the Western world,
the more you are hated
in your motherland."
Do you think that's still the case?
Has it got worse or got better
in the intervening years?
I wish I could say that.
We made a lot of progress in Turkey
in terms of freedom of speech,
but I'm afraid it's quite the opposite.
In 2006, I was put on
trial for writing a novel
called "The Bastard of Istanbul,"
which tells the story of a Turkish family
and an Armenian American family,
and it deals with memory and amnesia.
As you know, in Turkey, we
have a very long history,
rich history, but that doesn't
translate into strong memory.
In fact, I think it's quite the opposite.
We're a society of collective amnesia
and our entire relationship with the past
is full of ruptures.
And that void is filled
in by ultranationalists
and Islamist interpretations of the past.
So, when this book came
out, the novel came out,
I was put on trial for
insulting Turkishness
under Article 301.
This is an article in
the Turkish constitution,
which has been used against
journalists, against scholars,
but it was the first time it was used
against the work of fiction.
And it was quite surreal as well
because the words of fictional
characters were plucked.
They were taken out of the text and used
as evidence in the courtroom,
as a result of which my Turkish lawyer
had to defend my Armenian
fictional characters
in the courtroom.
So, your characters were on trial.
My characters were on
trial alongside myself.
Because you fought this.
And what happened?
So, that madness went on for about a year
and there were groups on the streets,
ultranationalists spitting at my pictures,
burning EU flags, because for them,
anyone who questions official history
is a pawn of Western powers.
And then I was acquitted
at the end of that.
What hold did that have on you,
because that sounds like it was something
to really live through?
It was quite unsettling.
I mean, I have to be honest to myself,
it did shake me quite a bit,
also because I was pregnant at the time.
So, the day I was acquitted,
the next day I gave birth.
Wow.
So, just one day apart, the
birth and the acquittal.
So, that whole year was
quite unsettling for me
and it was not that easy.
But of course, many people
go through so much worse.
So, I don't want to put
too much emphasis on that.
And at the same time,
I did receive amazingly
heartwarming letters
at the time from readers.
And the reason why I mention
where we are right now is,
a couple of years ago in 2019, again,
this time I was investigated
for crime of obscenity
for writing about sexual
harassment for gender violence.
I write about these issues
because this is the reality
of the land where I come from.
And what happened with
those investigations?
It did not turn into a trial.
But the very fact that police officers
come to a publishing house,
the very fact that they confiscate novels,
works of fiction and
they take to a prosecutor
is quite unsettling for authors.
Your works are a hugely successful
and widely read around the world,
that when you started writing in English,
I know that was a big deal for you.
But again, you've been labeled
a traitor for doing so,
at making your name easier
for Westerners to pronounce
and all of that.
But how much do you think
you've been targeted
because you're also a woman?
It's difficult to be a novelist in Turkey
because novelists deal
with issues about identity,
belonging, memory, amnesia.
The canvas of a novel is so nuanced.
It's not easy to be a novelist.
But honestly, I think it's much harder
or it's perhaps more difficult
to be a woman novelist,
because additionally,
you have to deal with
sexism and misogyny as well.
What is going on in Turkey
with regards to women
is extraordinarily bad
on many, many levels.
I mean, nearly every
day a woman is killed.
The levels of domestic violence
and how actually it's not investigated
is something that it cannot
almost be stressed enough.
The country leaving
the Istanbul convention
earlier this year, no reason was given.
That was all about a
document signed in Istanbul,
all about the prevention
of gender based violence.
What is your understanding,
just first of all,
of why Erdogan walked away from
that or his government did?
We have seen an escalation in
cases of femicides in Turkey
and there are so many other
stories that go uninvestigated.
For instance, there is
suspicious suicides,
are they really suicides?
So, this is an urgent issue
for women and children
and minorities in Turkey.
But instead of doing something about it,
instead of changing the laws,
and instead of implementing
Istanbul convention,
because signing it is not enough,
you need to ratify, you
need to implement it,
put it into practice.
So, instead of doing all that,
what the government did
was the exact opposite.
They also launched this very
horrible smear campaign,
misinformation saying
that Istanbul convention
is actually against
our traditional values.
And then one night, at night time,
the government decided to withdraw
from Istanbul convention
without really consulting women,
without really consulting
the civil society.
And ever since,
women have been bravely
on the streets protesting.
There are many women in Turkey
who are incredibly strong
and vocal and I have so
much respect for them.
And when you look at
academia, media, medicine,
you will find them everywhere,
but except in one field where
there are very few women,
especially as you go up the
echelons of decision making,
and that's politics.
And that makes a huge difference.
So, the ones who are making the decisions
are usually very patriarchal,
conservative men.
You used the word there femicide,
and actually not everybody uses it,
but nearly every day of
the year a woman is killed.
And that's only the
people who are recorded,
the women who are recorded in Turkey.
Do you think it's important as someone
who thinks all the time
about what words to use,
that that word is used
and that it passes into common parlance?
Yes. I think it's so important.
We need to use the word femicide,
we need to use the word misogyny,
but also we need to understand
that hate speech directed
against women is a crime
and it leads to other crimes.
So, every case shows this.
And I don't think I have
to mention social media
alongside the role of media,
in which, unfortunately,
it's always women who are put
under the magnifying glass.
What was she wearing?
What was she doing at
that hour of the night?
Why was she out?
Immediately or why didn't
she defend herself?
Immediately we start questioning women.
This narrative has to change.
And I think we also need to understand
that unfortunately with the pandemic,
we have seen an increase
in domestic violence
all across the world.
There was a recent report that showed,
in over 40 countries,
the amount of abuse
that women journalists,
women politicians,
any woman in the public space
have been receiving has escalated.
So, tech companies also need to wake up
to the fact that this is hate
speech we're talking about,
and they need to take it seriously.
With regards, of course,
I mean, men receive an awful
amount of abuse as well,
but it is augmented
differently towards women
and for what reason it is given.
And I suppose how you can tackle that.
I mean, some would say technology
is just reflecting the ills
that's already there in society.
And it's actually for society to change,
as opposed to the platforms,
but that has been a move
away from that position.
I think we need to talk
about tech companies
in a different way, in
the sense that for me,
particularly the digital platforms,
social media is a bit like the moon.
It definitely has a bright side.
Of course, it does connect us.
It does give people more voice,
especially in countries where
there are no media freedoms
or in countries where
there's no equal space
in the urban public space,
for instance, for women.
Many young women can carve
out a space for themselves
in digital platforms.
I do not belittle any of that.
However, because we have over romanticized
the bright side of technology,
and because we had this tech
optimism of early 2000s,
which was so arrogant as well.
Because the expectation
was if you bring Facebook
and social media,
every country is going
to become a democracy.
That's not true.
Because of all of that,
we urgently need to focus
on the darker side of
social media platforms.
And we need to understand how
they spread disinformation,
misinformation, and hate speech.
To come to, you know - I mean I would
The technology companies would say
they are working on that.
That is something they're now looking at,
or have been looking at.
I mean, I was reading
about your early life.
You said that books
saved you. Why was that?
My parents were in France.
I was born in France,
but afterwards they got separated
and my father stayed in France.
And in the meantime, my
mother brought me to Ankara,
to Turkey, to a very
conservative neighborhood,
very patriarchal neighborhood.
This was my grandmother's house,
but grandma herself was interesting.
She was a bit like a matriarch
and people would come to her
and her house was full of superstitions,
lots of stories of the
Middle East and oral culture.
Although, most of my upbringing
and my education was in Turkey,
I think I also felt the need
to start writing in English,
even though, as you can hear in my accent,
in my broken accent as well,
I'm an immigrant in this language.
English for me is an acquired language.
It's a much more cerebral connection.
My connection with the Turkish
language is more emotional,
but writing in English
gave me an additional sense
of freedom and I needed that.
To this day, I realize if my
writing has more sorrow in it,
if it has more longing or melancholy,
I find these things much
easier to express in Turkish.
Really?
But when it comes to humor, which I love,
and irony and satire, I find
that much easier in English.
What language do you dream in?
That's always the test.
Do you dream in both?
I dream in both.
I dream a lot in English.
When I'm writing in English, of course,
I dream primarily, mostly in English.
So, it can change?
Yeah, it can change.
I love asking people who
speak a few languages,
where they are with that,
because it's a bit of a
moment when you switch over.
That's so true.
And the mind is fascinating, isn't it?
Because it doesn't recognize
these national borders
that we take for granted.
You're not asked for your
passport in your sleep?
Not at all.
So, you can start the
same dream in Turkish
and end it in English.
And it also fascinates me
when I observe many immigrants
or many families from complex backgrounds,
sometimes they like to express
their anger or frustration
in one language or another,
so that switch back and forth.
It's so clever.
In the latest book, "The
Island of Missing Trees,"
why or what was the moment you thought
I'd quite like to write from
the perspective of a fig tree?
That was such a risk, to be honest.
I was aware that it
was risk for an author,
because if it doesn't work,
the whole thing collapses.
The whole edifice collapses.
But it felt like the right thing to do.
And if I may take a step back,
I've been wanting to write about Cyprus
for a very long time-
Which is what the book-
Which is where the book
partly takes place.
And it's a beautiful island
with beautiful people,
north and south.
But at the same time, it's a
very difficult story to tell.
And as you know, as we are
speaking, there's a border,
there's a frontier, partition line
that literally separates
Christians from Muslims,
Greek Cypriots from Turkish Cypriots.
So, depending on who you
talk to north or south,
there are clashing memories
and there are wounds and
the wounds are unhealed.
I couldn't find the gate into the story.
I've been thinking, reading, researching.
Only when I found the
voice of the fig tree,
it allows me to separate myself
from these nationalistic
boxes and take another look.
And then I felt more
free to tell the story.
But about what people don't say,
that's also a theme in the book.
And it's about what you
don't say to your children,
how you protect them,
potentially from painful pasts,
what you as a family have perhaps
fled from or escaped from.
You have two children
and I wonder how much
you've navigated that
with your own children,
what you say about why you
really left when you left Turkey.
Having your mother being
heavily pregnant with you
while being investigated in the way
that you've described to
me today is extraordinary.
Yes, these are not easy
conversations to have,
I'm aware of that.
At the same time, as a novelist,
I also love to be an intellectual nomad
to the best of my abilities.
So, I need to look at the story
from the perspective of
multiple generations.
And the reason why I say this is,
because I think in many immigrant families
or any family that comes
from a complex background,
there are these striking differences
as you move from one
generation to the next.
The first generation are usually the ones
who have experienced
the biggest hardships,
traumas, obstacles.
And they carry those memories within,
but they don't know how to
talk about them, so they don't.
The second generation,
especially after displacement,
they're not interested in the past.
And understandably, they
have to be forward looking.
They need to find their feet, build a-
New life.
Assimilate, tabula rasa,
let's move forward.
And therefore the third
or the fourth generations
in these families,
the youngest in these families
who are asking the strongest
questions about identity,
memory, their ancestors' journeys.
And I find that very striking
that sometimes you can meet young people
carrying old memories.
It's so true.
Have you made a decision
then based on that
to try and skip being the generation,
because you have moved and changed
that doesn't answer the
questions or comes forward.
Are you trying to disrupt that?
I want to disrupt that.
I want to understand those silences
because I think silences keep us apart.
And they also deepen and
widen the existing hurts
and inequalities,
but stories bring us together.
If we understand each other's stories,
then we can feel someone
else's psychology.
I am someone who thinks
about a lot about emotions.
And I think we're living
in an age of angst
and it's not easy to be young in this age.
It feels to me like many young people,
they have almost a
scream building up inside
and they want to unleash it at us
because they think we're destroying.
Rightly so, we're destroying
this world for them.
It's going to impact their future.
So, it's a moment of anxiety, fear,
disappointment,
bewilderment, anger as well.
But I think rather than
questioning these emotions,
the real question is what do
we do with these emotions.
What do we do with our anger?
What do we do with our anxiety?
Can we turn it into
something more positive?
There's only one emotion
that really scares me
and that's the lack of all emotions.
That's numbness, the moment we
stop listening to each other,
the moment we become indifferent.
The indifference.
That's I think a much
darker world to live in.
That scream of anger has made me recall
that I read you're a heavy metal fan.
Is that how you release, Elif?
I love heavy metal. I
always loved heavy metal.
Of course, you do.
That's exactly what I thought
when you walked in today.
Do you really?
I do.
I do very much so, since my early youth.
People don't expect a
middle aged Turkish woman
to love heavy metal, but I do.
Is that what you're listening to
when you wrote us the victory?
Yes, I do listen to heavy metal,
particularly the sub genres
like industrial metal,
gothic, more metal core,
Viking, Scandinavian.
Viking's my favorite.
I've literally got no idea
what you're talking about.
You also penned the 40 rules of love.
What's the most important one?
I think they're all related.
I think love is so powerful
and it transforms us
and we need to allow
ourselves to be transformed.
And I think one of the
rules mentioned in the book
is about freedom.
Where there's no freedom there's no love.
So, love is not about possessiveness.
My fiance, my partner, my girlfriend,
the emphasis is always on my,
but it's not about ownership, love.
Freedom and love makes me think
of your TED Talk back in 2017,
where just towards the end
you said you've never been
brave enough to admit that you,
I think you said it in the past tense,
that you were bisexual.
No, I said, I am.
You say I am.
But I never had the
courage to say it publicly.
And I watched that talk
and it is right towards the end
and it's great to hear
it in its full context.
But of course, what was taken
from that is you came out.
Yeah, of course.
And you had been scared of
the shame, the ridicule.
How has it been since?
Well, unfortunately
again, from my motherland,
the level of shaming,
ridicule, hate speech,
verbal abuse has been awful,
but I was ready to weather that storm.
And I wish I had the
courage to come out earlier.
Even though it's very
visible in my writing,
even though I've always been very vocal
about my support for LGBTQ+ rights,
I never had the courage to
say, also, this is my story.
But about with regards to feedback
or the comments coming
from listeners or readers
from other parts of the world,
it has been incredibly heartwarming.
And also, from my motherland,
I need to add this,
from families, particularly of children
who are LGBTQ themselves
or both young and older generations,
they have been very heartwarming
and very moving letters,
quietly whispering words of support.
But I had to go through that.
A lot of abuse afterwards.
It's interesting,
I was looking at some of the feedback
that was certainly public.
And there's this type that you described
in terms of the anti,
but there was also a
sense of, as I believe,
you're married to a man, why
did you need to say this?
We're beyond being able
to be in a position
where you have to come out anymore.
But of course, different
parts of the world
and different parts of society
are at such different
stages of that, aren't they?
And I wonder, do you still think today
it's important to be
able to say those things
or do you think we're
post that in some way?
I think it's always important
to share our stories.
And one of the things
that happens to us is,
when you live, when you
deal with authoritarianism,
when you deal with any ideology
or structure that divides
human beings into boxes
and denies their freedoms,
what happens is people feel very lonely.
People feel like,
"Am I the only one
who's feeling this way?"
But when you hear someone else's story,
then you realize you're not alone.
And that is very important.
There are amazing authors
from LGBTQ+ communities,
authors, poet, speakers,
who have given me amazing energy
and motivation and inspiration.
So, I felt like I had a responsibility
to share this primarily to myself,
but also to anyone who
might be feeling alone.
Elif Shafak, thank you so
much for talking to me.
Thank you so much.
Really appreciate it. It was fascinating.
Me too. Thank you.
Thank you so much for being with us.
And until we meet again, mask
up, stay safe and goodbye.